your d-back starter tonight corbin
martin his d-back's debut in los angeles
last week his first chase field
appearance is right now so usrimski
hitting 214 with six home runs
and he lines one to right in a base hit
and that's how this game gets started
holding down there posey lots of fly
ball out to right for josh rohan duke is
back there in the bullpen rojason right
makes a nice run and grab
and that's out number two
[Applause]
and the walk hunter windelstad the
empire third base saying no swing
and the walk and one of the better
hitters on the giants team with the
bases loaded stepping in the box brandon
crawford
hit well to right
into the gap and it flattens out
one run scores
two runs score
and as john miller would say
they'll all score and it's three-nothing
i mean it's just such a great reputation
to have and that is a guy who does well
with the bases loaded and that's what
brandon crawford has always seemed to do
he worked the count he got a challenge
fastball at the belt martin had to come
into him couldn't walk him
and that's what you do with a challenge
fastball and a hitter spot
swing and a pop-up
backing out
is the second baseman young and he makes
a catch in front of rojas
to win the other but the damage done on
the hill tonight for the giants will be
the veteran uh kevin gausman in his
eighth year at the big league level ten
start of the year
close pitch in a walk since his third
walk he's on base now for pavon smith
and he just dunks it in there drops into
right center marte will stop at second
two have reached against guzman well
when you're down three nothing early get
the national league rbi leader up there
escobar tied with miami's jesus aguilar
got him buster posey hangs on thank you
very much well you just sat down a guy
with 35 rbis and 12 home runs and you
did it with three swinging missed
fastballs
he hasn't got a feel of that split right
now so he's having a challenge
the two same it's nice to have a catcher
with strong claws isn't it
fastball at the knees strike three call
and the guardsman gets through the
trouble
and here's the two strike pitch high
fastball struck him out swinging that
looked like a two-seamer up
ain't gonna miss good split four
strikeout three pits see ya
split and the thing about a split when
he gets it going man that looks like
it's a hanger but it's still quick
movement and the beautiful thing too is
that
your arm action says fastball but the
pitch speed says change up
got him five strikeouts through two
innings
alex dickerson
dickerson hammers one to right and
spinning around is rojas it's going to
bounce into the seats for a ground rule
double here's longoria
longoria drives it left center field hit
well and out of here
center field longoria home run
number six on the season and the giants
lead six nothing it looked like martay
was going to play that one off the
bricks
but it went over the fence
he worked himself into a good count got
a challenge right at the belt over the
middle it's just a beautiful swing
barrels it up and he knows it you don't
see many go out over center field at
that part of the ballpark it's a high
fence so a base hit and a walk with one
out of the inning brings up andrew young
who could really cut into the sleep
got him 95 to right above the hands
strikeout number seven two on two out
the o2 pitch is swung on a missed strike
three gaussman gets him with the change
up of the splitter
two more strikeouts for kevin gausman
he's got eight through four innings it's
escobar who doubled in the third here's
the one-two pitch swing in the missy
struck him out with a 95 mile an hour
fastball
a little bit off the outside that's the
ninth strikeout for gaussman
runner aboard two down the pitch
grounded to second over to his left goes
solano he's on the edge of the outfield
grass straightens up flips it over the
belt for the out handing over harleen
garcia the new pitcher now for the
giants 11th time he's come in 16
strikeouts and 12 and a third
and he threw in the changeup and he
struck him out in three pitches and
that's the pitch he hasn't really been
able
to rely upon and that one right there
has been one of the best ones he's
throwing all year
you can't throw a better one than this
carson kelly
see the circle change grip
thumb and the forefinger on the side of
the ball forming a circle 3-2 pitch
swing gonna miss a fastball he
challenged him and
struck him out
and he struck out each of the first two
hitters of the inning
got him three pitches
wow
so garcia strikes out the side we'll
head to the seventh diamondbacks trail
at six nothing riley smith on for his
third inning in relief of corbin martin
carnell buster posey starts the seventh
buster slams this one to right he's got
to base it will it be more than a single
rojas does a good job as buster puts on
the brakes
fastball coming back how do you beat 92
mile an hour 2c movement you go the
other way
been doing it his whole career nice play
too by rojos sears longoria who has
walked homert and singled
longoria's got another hit
and posey's on the move
and posey
is coming in
longoria picks up another rbi and the
giants lead seven nothing
yeah i gotta believe buster posey was
running for longoria right there
it's a high 93
middle in finds a gap they had shaded
him over towards the right center field
side really exposed the gap he finds it
and with this jump buster posey running
like
there's no tomorrow
the giants have just quietly
made this a nice ball game as this is
hammered to left
and
off the bottom of the wall and it kicks
away from peralta and grandpa is headed
for third
and that's where he's going to end up
alex dickson getting a
fastball at 2c mover and
they kind of pinch the gap and despite
that
gets it off the wall gets himself a nice
break as the ball carribs away from
everybody cassalli only 6 for 59 this
year that's a 102 batting average
sally is going to blueprint into right
field for a base hit
so he'll pick up a single in an rbi and
it's eight nothing and he needed that
hit
so you're sitting here watching a ball
game all said whoop you're in the game
wind up with a knock and rbi
and the giants have a new pitcher it's
going to be sam selman it continues the
theme of tonight which has been
left-handers out of the bullpen giants
just for the fun of it trying to pitch a
shutout
and they will
is that'll end the ball game
they took advantage of a young pitcher
today
and they took advantage of a veteran
pitcher and kevin gausman on the mound
for them